okay so it's more and more likely that
Stargate is going to be getting a
cinematic movie from Amazon and MGM
and a lot of gators are not massively
happy about it we want a series
but actually does Stargate deserve a
cinematic release
should actually we be really proud that
this is what Amazon thinks
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
one of the first things I thought about
when I started hearing the rumors seven
or eight months ago now that Stargate
might actually be getting a cinematic
movie
was that Star Trek doesn't have a
cinematic movie they're making movies
but they can only make them to go
straight to streaming they can't get a
movie to go to the cinema because Star
Trek's not popular enough for that
so you know that was maybe me being a
little childish but still
it's a point
but if Amazon is thinking about a
cinematic release and we don't know for
certain I have to keep reiterating this
that is just what seems to be the plan
at the moment I actually am not 100
certain the final plan will be made
until production is well underway
but if that is what they end up doing it
does end up going to cinema
then
you know why is that a good idea
well for one let's remember that the
original Stargate movie is
still mgm's time 10th highest grossing
movie of all time so
that is not a bad place to start from
let's then remember that starga sg1 ran
for 10 seasons which at the time was a
record for a Sci-Fi show
let's then also remember that Stargate
Atlantis was incredibly popular let's
remember actually the Stargate
universe's numbers were never bad even
though the fans were a little divided on
it at times
some fans think sgu's the greatest of
all three Stargate today is actually
still the third most highly searched
thing on Google on sci-fi shows only
behind Star Wars and Star Trek
in the last two years Stargate sg1 or
stargazers regularly regularly
um ended up trending on Twitter
particularly after the sale of MGM to
Amazon went through and people started
to realize they're actually going to be
getting this show back
I'm walking the dog
I'm in North Wales again
if you actually look at Facebook traffic
as well Stargate is again one of the
most popular shows on there it gets
loads and loads of traffic loads and
loads of groups and all of those groups
have really good numbers on them so my
point here
Stargate and you should know this if
you're watching this video to be honest
it's quite popular still all of these
things it trended on Twitter it being in
the third highest search thing on Google
remembering that Star Trek and Star Wars
are actually still on our screens
Stargate hasn't been for over a decade
so really that just shows how popular
this is and how much
and how desperate people are for it to
return
Stargate is one of those shows that
doesn't age we can still watch it now on
freev or wherever it is that you can get
it all the DVDs or whatever and it's
still just as good as it was when we
first watched it hasn't dated at all
even though I remember in sg1 is what
nearly 30 years old now it first came
out so these are the reasons why Amazon
look at it and go Cinema massive
franchise we could actually yeah the sky
is actually the limit for this show and
his Gators why aren't we more proud of
that as Gators why aren't we going
Amazon think this is a big deal why
don't we why do we just want a TV series
for it when actually it can do maybe
more than Star Trek because it can
actually get bombs in seats at Cinemas
Star Trek can't
the confidence that Amazon seems to be
showing in Stargate that's something we
should be excited about
the confidence that they're showing
seems to be actually more confidence
than we've got even I said when it was
first you know talked about that they
were going to do the cinema first well I
said that's a massive risk what if it
fails at the cinema what if it bombs
would a TV show then even happen and I I
will be honest with you I want a TV show
more than I want a movie I want 10 hours
I want 20 hours of a season I don't
really want a two-hour movie unless that
is the start of something much much
bigger
but I am excited about it going back to
the cinema I am excited that Amazon
seems to have the confidence in it to
start there
and I actually think that is something a
skater should be quite proud of this is
a franchise that would have never ended
if it wasn't for mgm's financial
troubles I honestly believe that I
honestly believe that we wouldn't have
got those DVD movies that we were hoping
for we wouldn't have got the sg1 third
movie wouldn't have got the um Atlantis
movie that was planned because DVD sales
drop down but I think SGA would have
continued for at least another two
seasons it would have got the Seven
Seasons SGU would have probably ended up
getting Seven Seasons because the
numbers were improving the confidence in
the show was improving so we'd have got
that Stargate Universe probably would
have ended what what do they what would
that be now like eight years ago
something like that and we'd have
probably just got another series of
something new that would have maybe just
had its seventh season
I think we would have then got at least
a couple a streaming movies
because you know it would have been big
enough by then and MGM could have
cracked a deal somebody like Netflix to
do something like that
who knows who could have even got
another cinematic movie I honestly think
Stargate Universe was improving and was
would have got legs would have carried
on seven eight seasons maybe I actually
think then people like Brad right Robert
Cooper would have come up with something
new and we just carried on
I actually think then the Resurgence of
things like Star Trek a few years ago
could have meant that maybe I should
turn into the cinema with Stargate
whilst possible and I actually think
that you know actually in the last 10
years sci-fi has been massively popular
and we would have seen a Resurgence of
Stargate popularity with it but that
didn't happen only because of mgm's
financial problems not because the show
wasn't good enough
Stargate has such a vast Universe to
explore and so many different avenues
like the possibility of prequels it
actually makes sense when you look at
like the Ancients that I just think this
is a show that has legs and Amazon seem
to agree with us so for me the fact that
Amazon are going for a cinematic release
that's something to be excited about
that's something actually though as well
to be quite proud of yes I have my
concerns but
if that is the way they end up going
it's pretty cool
but I'd love to know what you guys think
if I convinced any of you with this
little bit of a rant or am I just
completely wrong no we want a series
screw the cinema
there is an argument to say a cinematic
release and the setting up a franchise
like this is a little bit old-fashioned
and maybe Amazon are forgetting that in
their bid to become a big cinematic and
Theatrical Studio rather than just a
streaming service
I'd love to know exactly what you think
get in the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com
soundtrack where most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports a channel you even get a free
gift
and you go to scitrack.co.uk add
dedicated website where we put articles
based on most of our new videos and we
try to add a little bit more information
for you to digest
please go check it out and as always
please stay safe
enjoy nature
and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]